yep
so we're gonna kick off in about three
or four minutes what we're gonna do is
we're gonna do like 30 minutes of just
talking about Rapids in general I want
to talk for the first half and I'm gonna
do Mike and then pass it to ki and then
after that we have about 50 instances of
GCP so hopefully everything will work
for everyone can just grab an incense it
should be pre-installed with KU DF & KU
ml play around with it there's some
datasets already loaded in the NFS
that's attached to the instance no
datasets news that's okay so grab your
own news that's oh they can be
downloaded from the can download
whatever dataset you can generate random
data and we also have the we can just
scrap like the first year of data from
the mortgage yeah and then also if any
one we have kind of oh we're not
starting yet
yeah we're just kinda just and uh anyway
and so afterwards I play around with
rapids or if people want to a lot of
developers are here so if there's any
issues and Rapids that you're like hey
you know what this issue is a really
small issue I just want to fix it
we would love people to do that as well
and so you know just like hack at Rapids
and add some functionality you know
we're just going to try to experiment
with that today so y'all are kind of
like our guinea pigs for this like rapid
Rapids hacking of functionality
I'm glad I got one person think we lost
me yeah
Lulu's video
I try to just unplugging the mini
displayport and putting back in
we just we lost a video on the TVs guess
I'm like a pure soul thinks this yeah
yeah computer is sending a signal
probably didn't know how to look for the
good that's what it's like like right
now my screen is showing that I'm
sending something signal a signal it's
not ice wish yeah I'm on it
HDMI and just watch you're like right on
that Bob make sure that connection
actually how what we can do well back to
my old school 80 days yep this region so
we lost our screens oh yeah so it's a
yeah maybe you guys set up the splitter
which I guess is this thing you know
what's working like two minutes ago okay
and then it just stopped is it possible
the power gap kicked and is it on
I think it's on my computer so charging
sound start yeah you know push gonna
shelf we could always just take the
splitter off and just use one monitor
what happened we'll be happy the other
half will just disappear
[Music]
just
I think this is reduced and they stopped
that was what my Thanos joke was for
half the only be happy other how could
disappear real quick oh yeah these
aren't working jobs that's easy yeah
[Music]
oh come back no I think just one car say
Bow Wow
are we really excited awesome
we got over here yep there
you turn it off an already I
pops up getting up there we go you need
to just go back to like yeah I do it one
more time thanks okay then we're going
to start in this break
it gets knocked out I think even if it
goes to sleep it'll probably go black
okay all right
can everyone hear me perfect so what
we're going to do is talk about Rapids
so briefly we're talking about Rapids
the library's kind of our development
process what we were thinking when we
were creating Rapids then Keith it's
gonna jump in talk about the dataframe
library some more are you gonna sure
notebooks oh yeah okay maybe we'll just
do that afterwards too and it was
swapped page and then afterwards we have
about 50 instances of GCP that we can
pass out for people to play around with
rapids kick the tires have some
functionality with some of the dev team
if you like and go from there so quick
introduction Josh Patterson director of
engineering at Nvidia I lead the rapids
project and Keith Crouch he's the
engineering manager for our data frame
library kudiye so data is growing
there's you know no hiding that and
because of this kind of growth of data
we see a lot of these big data systems
dupes Park the whole ecosystems really
just blossomed since you know 2011 and
one of the things that we realized very
early on both Keith and I prior to this
word Accenture a research lab and we
were doing a lot of kind of big data
systems and we just really just couldn't
keep up with the amount of data so we
kept scaling the larger and larger
clusters we're really excited when
Patrick kudu first came out and so we
were doing a lot with kudu as well but
we realized this is like we're just kind
of still getting inundated with data and
we're trying to build this cyber
security platform it's that's really the
basis of rapid it actually was us trying
to solve a cyber security problem and we
just started playing around with
graphics for you graph visualization
library that's
in GQ memory and some of the GPU graph
analytics libraries like blaze graph at
the time and so its awfull were drilling
the GPUs we could do in seconds and it
was actually keeping up with the volume
of data but all of our big data systems
were just you know we're just throwing
hundreds of nodes at it and it was just
getting slower and slower over time and
so we said what if we could take the GPU
acceleration that we were doing for
graph analytics and then apply it more
generally to essentially ETL like things
machine learning etc and so we kept
playing around with GPUs but we realized
or some kind of some barriers to
adoption there's a lot of data movement
so every time we want to do something
with a GPU we're moving data back from
post memory to device memory and back
and forth that really kill produc
productivity and then there were three
makeshift data formats early days of GPU
programming every library want to do
things in a slightly different way there
was no kind of concept of
interoperability between libraries and
so even if I did want to keep something
on the GPU the GPU libraries could talk
to each other so I would still have to
send it back to host do some type of
copy and convert and then bring it back
writing CUDA C++ it's hard most of the
data scientists that we were working
with at Accenture labs were Python Scala
Java developers and so writing CUDA
kernels was uh it's not the most
pleasant thing and at the time there was
really no great Python api's outside of
deep learning
and so when we join a video one of our
first things to do was connect a boolean
GPU memory database map D now omni's I
to something like Raftery so what we
wanted to do was show that we could hold
essentially about a month's worth of
cybersecurity data for this large firm
and be able to do real-time queries of
like here's different patterns and
NetFlow and different types data and
then visualize these graphs so here's
the people coming into the network
here's what advice they were propagating
to etc the query side was taking
sub-second the visualization tide was
taking some second but moving data
between map d congrats tree would take
essentially about 90 seconds to two
minutes
mainly because of the copying it back to
hos converting in the copying it back
and so if you have a machine that has
you know a door
now with the gtx 216 GPUs and you know
sixteen GPUs can do things really fast
but then if I'm trying to copy you know
all that data back to host memory I
still only have two cores or sorry two
sockets of CPUs to work with and some of
the copying converting would always our
biggest bonnet so we realize we have to
do something where we could essentially
get rid of this just keep data on the
GPU pass it back and forth between
applications really leverage things like
CUDA IPC and other protocols so we just
have one library communicate with the
next library and and hopefully just past
pointer to the data we never really
wanted to copy data at all
also GPU memory is scarce so most GPUs
are 16 gigabytes
now with the V 132 and so one of these
we wouldn't use also remove copying so
even copying was kind of a problem
because we just didn't to run out of
memory on the GPU and so at the same
time
Apache Aero was really kind of picking
up steam so this was around 2016 and so
I really love this diagram I think it
very succinctly just says what the
problem is in the big data world
everyone was serializing DC rosa
deserializing data between these
different applications and what did they
wanted to move to was basically arrow
and everything could just read and write
arrow we want to do the exact same thing
the GPU every application on the GPU
could just read a right arrow
essentially the beautiful thing about
this was there's not that many cheap
libraries that were doing
data science so basically saying hey
this is a standard wasn't very easy when
you had something like Apache Aero or
just like okay boom done that's what
we're doing the GPU and so that's really
the foundations and the background of
rapid so rapid
it's basically Apache Aero is how we
represent data in memory and then on top
of that we have different libraries
Couty off our data frame library who ml
our machine learning library cout graph
graph analytics library and then we have
integrations with things like pi torch
and chain er 2 pi for deep learning and
then we have a host of different
visualization integrations we recently
released a library called QX filter
which was essentially a nod to the
original cross filter library
essentially does cross filtering on the
GPU and then you connected to things
like kepler GL or d3 or whatever you
know visualization library you want and
so this top habit slide actually claimed
from a spark slide so essentially we're
replicating a lot of what happened in
the traditional Big Data community but
just one GPUs so instead of reading your
writing from HDFS spark keeps everything
in memory similar to that we want to
keep everything in GPU memory so instead
of reading and writing back to system
memory let's just remove all that leave
everything on the GPU
let's have protocols for communication
standards as well as a host of libraries
to do everything from group bys joins
you know string functionality reading
different formats
Parkay json xml what-have-you directly
an arrow on the GPU and we really try to
keep as much on the GPU for as long as
possible and with that we're staying
pretty amazing performances games
and one of the reasons why this is
possible is really because of just kind
of how in video works we basically are
working with the stack all the way up
from the Coonan level and the hardware
all the way up to the application so
Rapids is fully open source and all of
our algorithms are open source but we
also can go back to some of the CUDA
engineering where like hey this
functionality in CUDA doesn't really
work for this application can you add
this or can you write that even all the
way down to the hardware acceleration
and so there's some really cool things
that you know we can do with the tensor
boards we're experimenting with new
things with the the ray tracing cords to
do different types of distance
calculations for things like KNN and so
that a lot of that's still very
experimental but it's really amazing
that we can actually go over to the
hardware guys and be like hey you know
if you guys would add this in the next
generation it would really help you know
this part of the data science workflow
that we have and so I think that ability
to iterate it one of the reasons why we
can move very quickly the rapid so
Before we jump into all the details how
to get it currently you can download
source code from github
kondeh install we should have pip
install in the next couple of weeks and
also containers docker hub or in GC
video GPU clout take questions at the
end
actually we can we have time sure go for
it
or you just do like parquet we're gonna
we're gonna touch on the eller eating
coyote like file loading into GPU memory
yes but you don't have to like
constantly do it over over reading and
writing from parquet you ideally would
want to do that once so read from
parquet and then it's been how large
your data is obviously and how many GPUs
you have but and then
yes
[Music]
correct
so first we just start talking about
some of the machine learning and graph
analytics I'd ultimately here's our
poltroon map and video spent a lot of
their time starting in the deep learning
space and essentially we're just
expanding out so I think most people
think of GPUs it's almost anonymous now
with deep learning we want to do the
same thing for machine learning and so
we spent a lot of time with GB teens
creativeness decision trees and XE
boosts and now we're just essentially
expanding out to more things so random
forests linear regressions k-means
cannon
we had a graph library in B graph that
was sync with GPU we're gonna expand
upon that as well we're bringing in some
other open source libraries like gunrock
a lot of the work out of Georgia Tech
the Hornet which is now stinger actually
now it's sorry it's now we're gonna it
was stick okay yeah was 14 out it sorry
what stinger now Hornet and so we're
bringing that into the ku graph
framework as well and I'm gonna talk
more about some of the performance
improvements but I don't know if you all
can see the chart on the right-hand side
of the screen I'm but essentially about
a 90 X improvement one actually boos one
about a 100 gigabyte data set so we show
kind of the scalability as you increase
the data size and the time and so that's
pretty impressive and just from some
like some field like success stories
we've heard some customers say they
taken hundred node actually boost
clusters and basically you've moved it
down to a single GG x2 and they're still
getting about a 20 to 25 X improvement
and so the density of GPUs is really
exciting I'm gonna talk about that for a
little bit so our first first real work
flow was just looking at mortgage data
so we took all the mortgage data that's
publicly available from Fannie so it's
about 400 gigabytes of data and so would
you have two data sets you have
acquisitions performance so raise your
hands you're familiar with buying a
house
okay so like this middle section of
people and that guy okay so when you buy
a house there's like really two
processes to it first you apply for a
mortgage
and that's the acquisition side and then
you have your payment history so you
keep paying it over time as a as a
mortgage lender you actually want people
to pay for their mortgage for all the
term so 1530 years what have you you
don't want people to prepay you also
don't want people to default so
prepaying in defaulting at both bad so
you want people to apply for a loan get
a loan pay that loan over time and so
with this data set you have two dates
that should have the acquisition side
which is borrower characteristics your
your FICO score your debt to income your
income itself and then all these other
various characteristics of the borrower
and then you have their payment history
over time and so what we wanted to do
was essentially combine those two
datasets and figure out based on current
characteristics of a loan current you
know state and temporal occupy owners
like how the median family income is
doing at a certain time in a state with
this loan either prepay or default in
the next year so kind of a simple
exercise so we combine these two
datasets we join them we do this kind of
rolling window to figure out when the
loans actually or what's happening to
this alone in the next year to fill in a
training set and then we hold some of
the data out-of-sample to do predictions
and so the ETL processing of that so the
joins the group buys all the different
variable creation you can see what is on
a 20 no 50 note and 100 notes bar
cluster these are a core nodes 64
kilobytes so they're relatively you know
weak nodes but pricing wives like the
cost of 16 GPUs on AWS is roughly
equivalent to about 30 nodes so if you
wanted to put this somewhere on this
chart
where's dollars $4 the same it would be
somewhere right around here and then
here's the processing time of 20 knows
50 and 100
doing the Indian processing with kudiye
takes about 40 seconds on a dgx to the
ml prepped is a little bit longer
because we're copying all the data back
from system memory in arrow in the
system side and then back to the GPU and
then we're doing extra boost training
and so this is kind of different scaling
up with more cheap use versus scaling
out so DG x2 has 16 P 132 goodbye GPUs
and they're fully connected with mV
switch verses 5 DG x1 so 8 GPUs per node
and then we have them connected by 4
InfiniBand 100 Gig nix and so this is 40
GPUs and this is 16 so this does perform
faster especially on ETL but what we
really found interesting I'll just jump
to it we found interesting is they
actually whose time between 40 GPU
versus 16 wasn't that drastically
different and it was really just going
out to network kind of hurts performance
a little bit and so that was a really
interesting thing another interesting
thing is if we had a smaller data set
where we never had to write it back to
system memory so obviously with 400
gigabytes of data we can't keep that all
in GPU memory and do processing so we
had to write the intermediate results
back to system memory here with the 35
gigabyte aset we can actually keep it
fully in GPU memory the whole time and
so you don't actually have this ml prep
time you don't have to feel I have to
move it back and essentially going from
arrow to D matrix that's a pretty much
an instant conversion and so instead of
having this time and ready just
essentially goes to 0 and you still get
the the speed ups of machine learning
and so one of our of our engineers on
Rapids he actually placed eighth in the
plastic cattle competition and so a lot
of what he was doing was this was
essentially just reading in data
processing it and then running exe boost
in China bootstrap labels for an RNN
ultimate training of this data set to
predict essentially stars and how to
classify stars and so we're gonna blog
coming out about that in a few days but
it's a really cool example of
when you can do things fifty to a
hundred times faster he basically said I
have no knowledge of interstellar
classification and he didn't really even
try to understand actual properties of
stars it was just kind of more of a a
brute-force I'm just gonna do a bunch of
feature engineering and then I'm going
to run it through actually booth and
then bootstrap that to feed into an RNN
and you know he basically placed eight
out of a thousand people
it was a little bit outside the money
but pretty impressive results just kind
of showing but one single cheap you can
do with brute force
yeah
[Music]
that is correct and so there's a very
common thing once you get past like 20
nodes on SPARC you're really not gonna
get it significant more improvement on
actually booth so you have to start
scaling up because of communication and
so just one of those it's actually a
like a really tough business problem
what do you do when you have a larger
data set that you want to run some type
of create this decision tree on and you
know that scaling out doesn't really
help you so then you have to start
buying these fatter and fatter nodes and
so that's actually one of the prime
reasons why we build rapid is so you
just have more density with GPU so if we
know that scaling out is going to lose
performance and you can scale up a lot
further than what GPUs it improves the
total compute time
and here's a few more so these are
single GPU benchmarks so comparing just
a single v-102 a 20 core cpu t SVD pca
and DB scan and so within rapids we've
released those three algorithms single
GPU we've integrated facebook's kan from
face and we have k-means as well in our
next release in a couple of weeks we're
going to have common filtering GLM and
point six we're gonna have random forest
ARIMA and you map so i don't know if
people are following in the PI data
community Leland McKinney's he has this
really cool dimensionality reduction
library called you map and it performs
significantly better than most methods
and it has a really great visual
clustering of data when you map it out
and luckily it is a very parallelizable
algorithm and so it's essentially a
cannon with a stochastic gradient
descent on top of it which are both
things that we can do well in the GPU so
we're really excited about working with
him to to implement that so we have a
couple engineers working on that and we
should have that out in the March
timeframe and then finally crap and so
we're just looking at pip installs for
Network X and one of the surprising
things is how many people are using
network acts just graph analytics and on
the other side of the world we spend a
lot of time on the kudos I think about
graph so we had a MV graph for probably
three years now but these two worlds
just never talk to each other and so the
envy graph was really just for HPC you
know people who were very used to CUDA
programming and network tax is a very
straightforward pythonic way of doing
graph analytics and so KU graph is kind
of one of our things we just want to
make it very simple and network adds
graphics like for people to do graph
analytics but get the speed of GPUs and
so you know here's just some you know
early benchmarks of our PageRank first
is network access PageRank and then
we're just going through the algorithm
of breath
Serg triangle counting Jaccard
similarity and just systematically doing
single emotion GPU implementations for
all these graphing analytics and then
having Python interfaces where they can
read and write to arrow as well as other
format COCs are etc and then we're talk
about Kuti upper but really like this
diagram when we first launched Rapids
Jensen our CEO he was like you know kind
of I wanted to feel what a what a day in
the life of a data scientist was like
and it's kind of a kind of a hard thing
to diagram out what a data scientist
does it's one of our designers he was
kind of just sketching out different
things we kind of had some doodles and
then he had some quacks and you gotta
kept playing around with any kind of us
you know stumbled upon this and we
really liked it and it's kind of true it
so well we didn't ask g'way the the guy
who did a lot of archival competitions
you know how is it now
versus with Rapids and so let me be Don
wrapped around three months there's a
lot of like this is kind of where we
ideally want perhaps to be there is now
a lot of huh this is undocumented this
broke then he has to go ask us and we
have to like hotfix something for him
but hopefully in the near future it'll
be this seamless people are just doing
workflows they're powering through
things and just as a comparison we were
on the fast AI forums and we're talking
about the same cattle competition and a
lot of people were spending you know two
to three hours just doing group bys on
the data and other simple manipulation
because the data set was about 20 or 30
gigabytes and they're like it wasn't
really useful if we had some type of
cheap heal accelerated way to do some of
these feature engineering we're like
well we're glad you said that because
there is and he did it and here's how he
did it so that was really exciting to
show people who actually had pain points
a day someone who is doing it already on
GPUs and you know doing these same like
group buys it essentially in tens of
seconds
which is the way did they speak up
during infancy or that is possible and
like with the RTS 8000 my GPU and so
most companies uh we're talking about
connected car major Victoria Beckham
after all their data or a whole new
years you know you could put that on the
single GPU and then do the second so if
I make the import icon unknown any
people that Andy's no attacks but I'm
looking to you
I do think that I would also add where
kind of line things that were ready
focus time across the rebels ecosystem
is solving the data pipeline problems
for you so you don't have to build that
really annoying and non-performing blue
code in order to get data from one
library to another library to another
either we basically we standardize
around Apache aerostatic libraries and
handoff data to one another really
really efficient rate and when
conversions need to happen we handle
that for you on the GPU which makes it
almost free
okay so that I'm gonna talk about kooky
Africans are kind of GPU and data frame
library time to browse I leave a lot of
Python development on qu TF and kind of
some of these other rapid libraries and
so could be up it's a GPU accelerated
data frame library that's based on the
Apache era of data format but is exposed
to end users with a pandas like API I
would say it's like 95 99 percent of the
same purpose very small differences kind
of the main one being that we don't
support multi indexes on rows but it
kind of it exposes all the things that
you normally use pandas for today you
feel like your future engineering stuff
like you Narine binary ops joins merges
group buys filters usually the find
function to about touch on more later
because there's a really cool things
that we can do there with the Python
ecosystem and GPUs and then also some
accelerated kind of i/o type things like
loading CSV easily mark a day won't work
etc and how we can actually leverage
these to accelerate those days and so
who do you have today
it's kind of it's really two parts there
is a kind of CUDA implementation
underneath the C C++ API and then there
is Python bindings on top of it that
make it look and feel like pandas as
well as integrated within kind of
and so kind of on the CUDA C++ side you
have a usable API and then it also kind
of exposes a lot of your lower-level
mechanisms like importing and exporting
data about cheating on the GPU using a
PC which is inter-process communication
it's basically a virtual handle that you
can think of like a pointer to allow you
to share data across different processes
without having to actually kind of
serialize the data and copy it off the
GPU example it has all those kind of the
low-level CUDA kernels as well as like
thrust calls for example to perform all
of your kind of like l1 element-wise
math functions and other kind of
reduction functions groove bys joins
etcetera and then also things like
sorting and kind of all the operations
they end up being low-level CUDA
implementations in order to kind of
squeeze out the most performance
possible and then kind of type of
interface on top of it like I said we
integrate with
ecosystems so things like numpy array is
pyro tables pandas dataframes
anything with a memory view we can
import and then also we use the Dumbo
library heavily so for those of you who
are not familiar number is a
just-in-time compiler in library
database that allows you to write 30
naive Python function and then it will
compile it down to machine code and you
can target that for either CPU or the
GPU and so what that allows us to do is
basically say say you're missing a
function that you need within to the
other you have some kind of custom
that isn't really exposed in the normal
pandas or to the API instead of using
like apply in canvas land and having to
execute in pure Python you use apply in
Korea and it actually JIT compilers that
function to GPU code that executes stuff
on the GPU so you still get the GPU
accelerated scheme and I will add pandas
it's somewhat easy to get out of doing
vectorized kind of operations and
panthous we make it very difficult to do
that in Korea without hiding kind of the
functionality and so in general because
to do it include EF it will run on the
GPU and it will run fast
okay all right and kind of along along
with PDF we have recently yes so we
recently recently released a string
library for doing the kind of string
operations on the GPU and specifically
larger reigns insurance and so kind of
the API is going to follow and of the
pent the API and functionality is going
to Penn mirror kind of the pandas kind
of string functionality as you can see
here some like initial performance
results means I probably improved quite
a bit since we done this work but kind
of things like lowered and burning
string to lowercase finding a substring
of finish training or slicing a string
we're seeing really really nice videos
and we're going to be working over the
next couple months to integrate this
nicely within kudiye to provide a more
native kind of string data type than
what kind of pandas provides and kind of
in you know we like we like to work with
big data you know a single GPU who you
have it's a single GP library my data
likely isn't going to kick in a 16-bit
532 be my card in a lot of situations
and so we're kind of trying into the
Python ecosystem or by using a library
called bath and so that is a distributed
computation scheduler that allows you to
scale your Python workloads from
anything from just using all of the
cores available in your laptop to
running on like a thousand nodes
supercomputer cluster and what's great
about that especially from a rapid
perspective and using it for GPUs is
that it's extremely modular that makes
scheduling
compute data communication handling like
outpour or caching etc it's all really
modular and so we can kind of replace
things as needed with their own
implementations and kind of augment
things to make it more GPU friendly more
GPU performance and so what this allows
us to do is basically run the native ask
worker from a node and point each worker
to a single GPU in order to kind of have
your exact same code that would run a
single GPU run multiple GPUs within a
note and then also run on multiple GPUs
across multiple nodes in the future and
we're doing we're doing some additional
work to kind of improve the data
communication performance and bass and
make it more GP friendly to take
advantage of techniques like GPU remote
direct memory access which then can use
like high performance networks that can
fit a band and hundred gig Ethernet with
leg rocker and so kind of delay the way
this works it uses the kudiye primitives
underneath exposes kind of the same high
level API that you're used to and then
instead of kind of today this name today
that you can do single node multi-gpu
and instead of using kind of the typical
task data transport of serialize data
than shipping over a TCP socket what we
actually do is get those CUDA inter
process communication
handles and ship those and then the
remote worker reads that handle and copy
gpgpu to GPU peer-to-peer and so then
that will take advantage of things like
envy link or PCI Express particular
copies which gives you like an order of
magnitude better performance than
serializing and shipping over a TCP
socket and then kind of we're working
towards now engineer these hopefully in
the next two months we're working with
the library you can use X which will
then allow us to kind of do the same
thing across multiple nodes and so using
using like Lola using network InfiniBand
hundred gate you can have a copy to do
remote memory accesses across nodes
without the data ever having to go back
to hosts memory first
[Music]
[Music]
yep you depend kind of towards the
future is what we will handle doing even
if you just have a single GPU we will
handle doing out of core and spilling to
system memory and then moving it back to
the GPU is necessary but the whole idea
is you just point just your large data
set we figure out how to partition it
how to perform all those operations
across the different workers on it and
you don't worry about that at all
that's word from the network password is
actually faster
[Music]
[Music]
but you might have more Portuguese still
having access to 100 terrorist data
really exciting and so then kind of on
the machine learning side and the graph
side it's kind of we're doing the same
thing for the desk but instead of using
kind of open u CX and handling it in
kind of the traditional analytics great
elastic way it's it's you're kind of
more static way we're like in the ML
world if if a worker dies you just kind
of have to restart going together you
don't really want to run the algorithm
for too much because it's just not
important
and so what mask allows us to do is it
allows these workers to easily make
calls to basically lower level
communication library that allows a few
things like MPI or Nicole kind of
whatever other collective communication
library to do really efficient
communication and just allow the task
workers to make high level calls to
essentially kick things off synchronize
things in five
and so kind of looking towards the
future over the next few months with the
GP data frame we're looking to just
continue improving functionality and
performance single GPU single node
multi-gpu and multi node multi-gpu with
strings we're looking to integrate it
basically integrate it completely into
qdf where we want you to be able to do
string operations on a column of your
data frame and not even have to think oh
god I'm working strings this is going to
be slow how do I do this we wanted to
just kind of feel natural new strengths
on a community and then we're looking to
expand our accelerated a data loading
accelerated i/o support and so today we
have a GP of soda to the CSV reader that
we're constantly adding additional
functionality and performance
improvements to it follows the Panda 3
needs new API
we're seeing a more than 10x the
improvement over pandas
we're not quite at future party yet but
we're quickly working up to it we have a
park a reader which is a work in
progress and it's going to follow the
API and Padmasri project as well so
still easy to use very consumable and
then we have a cork reader that there
should be
a public pool request going out
relatively soon as well and then kind of
an after City leader party leader or
creator and further along we're looking
at things like JSON XML hdf5 etc and of
all of your standard typical file
formats that what we've seen what we've
seen actually is that if we rely on
canvas or other libraries to do die out
for us if that's actually becomes the
bottleneck in the workload more than
doing the rest of the feature
engineering because it happens on and on
the kind of on the left here this is a
chart from the Apache very long so and
basically what it shows is that you know
if you have a performant file system the
CPU actually quickly becomes the
bottleneck in getting your data into
memory and so for us if we if we
leverage the compute capability of GPUs
we can actually accelerate this quite a
bit and get this data kind of ready to
do feature engineering on
and also so we've been working with
anaconda and other members of community
to kind of help drive this thing called
the Python CUDA array in the face and so
it's similar to the not prior interface
but it's basically a standard metadata
on how to describe and dimensional
arrays on GPUs and basically the idea
behind this is to allow different GPU
array libraries to talk to each other
efficiently and not have to essentially
copy back the hosts memory and numba
HIDA then just copy back to the exact
same data format and so the first
adopters are number two pi and pi torch
and so number kind of has bi-directional
put away interface where basically you
can go from up high towards CUDA tensor
to enough that device array and there's
actually zero copy zero conversion
basically same thing compiled a number
of coop I actually supports it very
maybe coop I supports coming in as well
so you can pass between another device
right there PI torch could a sensor to
zero copy basically just access the
pointer to the data you're good to go
pi torch supports that array interface
node out there it's work in progress and
supporting it coming in so you can't
quite yet create apply too much crude
attempt sir we're sorry you can't quite
yeah you can't quite yet create a pipe
which could sensor and these
and so join the movement kind of patchy
arrow Rapids the gpo catalyzed
initiative
well opens worse just trying to kind of
leverage the power of GPUs and improve
kind of the data science and
gpu-accelerated way of sizing for
systems where any kind of bug reports
issues feedback future classes
documentation anything it all really
really helps us and especially it really
helps us to prioritize our development
and understand where the gaps in the
community are that we should try to
address and we want to give a huge shout
out to the Google cloud platform they
provided us what instances to kind of
get you all to live income tires today
and in just a few minutes we're going to
finish up those up and then kind of work
and futures together or even just kind
of using PDF so huge huge shout out for
doing that and then the rapid rapid
container is also available on cube flow
today and so with that take any question
for
the old sock will work on the windows as
well or say so the question is does the
software work on Windows or Linux as of
today minutes only
we haven't decided on Windows support
yet there was something there are some
blockers on the cooler side as to
whether popping us I believe some of
them are fingers off I'm not trying to
stab all of them it's it's on our minds
if it's possible we will support it in
the future but we can't make any
promises
[Music]
basically yep so the only other thing
I've said is we are exposing like a C
C++ API as well for non Python users and
this also allows us to expose it to
other languages in the future things
like R or kind of any other language
that can consume us in C++ that
controller like I'm the python said yes
we aren't mirroring the panas api
scikit-learn api network x api to make
it really easy using consumable for kind
of traditional developers and data
scientist not quite yet we are actually
going to just provide you an IP address
that you can SSH into to play ok as far
as I know we do not have any kind of we
don't have any kind of a Meyer necklace
possibly in the future today that that
says just to spit out the container
which it gives you will completely set
up environment ready to go and also had
some demo
I made a man named and they might would
probably end up just looking like
installed any Conda create an
environment the Condon saw so almost
anything where you're accessing them
we're essentially accessing a large
majority of video so joins group by
element wise operations unary operations
kind of any operation where you're
having to scan the data and they're not
essentially just doing a random access
unlike a single element you'll see
pretty massive speed ups
for using cootie up yes like as we
continue to improve support for da cunha
if you use that No
[Music]
he's responsible
the plastic
so it depends it depends on the
operation so for things like things like
element-wise operations or things that
you things that are like embarrassingly
parallel it's just like a simple each
each worker does its own thing with
kudiye okay they're things like joins
group buys where it's more like you need
to actually communicate between the
workers then there is specific
algorithms built into that to the other
hand I guess I'm not following the
question
so yeah so delay the way that prop the
communication works today I'll play
Nepal today and how it's going to be in
the future so today in the KU DFT
library there are custom serialize and
deserialize functions that register with
desk to desk allows you to register
essentially custom functions as to how
do I serialize this object into
something I can ship over a wire and out
of a deserialize today basically our
serialized function just gets in the
crude IPC handle so this inter process
communication handle that can be shipped
over there by the deserialize call
basically reads that handle and then
copies the data to a local GPU and so as
far as - gets concerned basically
whenever it needs to communicate data
between workers it's essentially just
shipping like you can imagine a single
864 basically and then the rest of the
ask the actual data movement happened at
a low level in essentially the Nvidia
driver basically handling a peer to peer
to peer copy in the future we're looking
at using a system called open you see X
and then in like learning address
analytics will be looking at
using like a collective communication
framework like nickel or MPI and so in
that case task is basically just making
a call in to essentially what would be
like a wrapper on top over the C++
function which then handles all of that
communication kind of below down yes so
so it's different between so like the
PDF for example it will handle a bit
failure and then we schedule work on to
a different worker and basically if it
needs to if it needs to say let me start
earlier stages based on like the task
craft it will do that on to a different
worker for qu a melaku graph because you
can't you can't really handle that
elasticity in a like performant way
basically you can think of the jobs more
like barriers where if any worker fails
during the job it needs to essentially
be start that job and so then at that
point it'll just act as a barrier if any
of them a little kick off all of them
they gotta cross workers and then the
task workers you can run them with
what's called the nanny process which
would basically detect hey this worker
failed I need to actually restart this
workers so it's ready for more
libraries
it's it's very like we just released it
a month month and a half of that yeah
yeah but is there are there plans for
this might be no question
Blandford with jet engines or anything
like that like that tonight but I
recognize understanding of the ante uses
the
yes a long answer is yes but we're going
to have to go back in the grass which is
why I love browse the much much longer
answer is if you think of strength
question of grass or Juventus their
relationship to each other or
connections or other things represent a
paragraph etcetera to do more
complicated regex technique very quickly
okay and so we do always that's more
than theoretical if you like implement
in a very package plate and now turn
production Eliza so regex is coming I
make
like yeah
yeah surprise actually this design is
about being in the video
things that general public no that's too
complex you can't do that yeah research
paper on infinity no they don't really
care about any other questions
generally
and to this wide
one of the temperatures being alive
screaming and so lucky possibly get to
Mexico every second
yeah come to us using today
renting the team up both internally and
externally so we have
yeah we're using it the goal though is
to make more feature complete there's
still a lot of issues right now we have
446 issues onto the airplane
so we're firefighting it is keeping
development the excitement
I have another question about gratitude
what sort of / Gators today CSR
accountant CEO in the future or MIT
intern alcohol on it is because we're
already a mortgage slightly but
something that's would be very selective
or I think at the last graphic treatment
of those your earplugs
[Music]
the clothes will be the format but it's
essentially a dynamic CSI
think about all the great things about
CSI depression plus the ability to alter
[Music]
I'm just getting stuff ready to go for
the coupon it's as if people have other
questions
they introduce me
[Music]
[Music]
also we're hiring because you knew you
were you know secret of Python long
psyphon and I come from a really fast
car all
I think feel free to keep answering
questions but myself and then a couple
the rapid developers so we have Paul
over there and then Dante we're gonna
walk around hand out IP addresses for
GCP instances that you can kind of just
SSH into and start getting the tires and
kind of a lot of information will be up
here feel free to keep asking questions
absolutely
I send you all these or should we just
start at the top
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mom it's only for cars alright 35.5 206
and then using password
[Music]
[Music]
3220 and sorry
so Linda in there there is a Content
writer with call graphics just need to
switch density wrap it and then you can
install whatever you want it has to be
elderly you forgot to install ipython
and Jupiter unfortunately it's free to
install
[Music]
I think we mean enable
2:21
22:06
either punny
the best
six
right 35 about two thirty to forty four
to thirty thirty five to thirty 2.1 90.1
six minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
35.2 32 we've got 130